[Music]
I definitely you definitely heard this
song
no wait maybe not I don't know
like a little girl what spitting some
words and then like a little nursery and
so she's innocent on the surface but
she's like a bad girl she's gonna show
everyone on the dance floor like she got
the Rhythm she got the moves you know
but like you got to work a little to
kind of get her out of her shell she's
very into pop she's very interesting
she's very into pop
it's like a piano piece a little bit of
this you know synthesizer voice
I think we found our girl I think we
found our girlfriend right now I'm gonna
assume it's K-pop I don't know if this
is if this is black pink or Girls
Generation he knows his K-pop but I know
this person jams out to K-pop I mean I
feel like she's like a very upbeat happy
person like bubbly